right Lebanon's Parliament has passed
its 2020 budget as it tries to lift the
country out of a deepening economic
crisis protesters had tried to block
politicians from getting into the
Parliament to vote many rejected the
budget as it have been discussed and
amended by the previous administration
riot police were deployed some
demonstrators were physically removed
from the Parliament precinct let's go
live now to our correspondent Sarah Kyra
she's there outside Parliament I believe
Sarah and many of those protesting are
complaining about the fact that this is
a budget that was actually passed by the
former regime by the former authorities
that's correct Marcy now they've just
passed this budget is the 2020 budget is
much delayed because this was approved
by the previous government they had
decided on it and they made changes to
it in December and of course the
protests happened which delayed this
budget getting through now a total of 49
MPs out of 76 that were attending voted
to pass this budget of course there's a
hundred and twenty eight MPs in total
now the reason why there's a gap in
those that attended and those that
didn't was because some of them decided
not to they said it is unconstitutional
to push this budget through and the
reason why they've been saying it's
unconstitutional is depending on article
and article which stipulates that the
new cabinet must receive a vote of
confidence first by the Parliament
before they can make decisions on big
things such as the budget now this was
the fastest time in Lebanese politics
where a budget has been passed this
quickly of course because of years of
civil war as well there's ten years they
didn't even have a budget that was ever
approved now protesters are not happy
and the reason why they say they're not
happy as they said that the economic
crisis is getting worse and pushing
through this budget is not actually
addressing the major problems that are
happening within the Lebanese economy
and the reasons as to why they're even
protesting in the first place all right
Sarah kyrat with the very latest from
Beirut thank you